evaluate the expression nine-halves
times X times 12 when X is equal to 1/4
so we just have to put 1/4 in here for X
so this expression becomes 9 halves
times 1/4 times 12 now we could just
evaluate this multiply 9 halves times
1/4 and then multiply that by 12 but a
slightly faster way or a way that'll
maybe reduce the chances for errors
would be to reassociate this one I mean
that is you instead of doing the 9
halves times 1/4 first we can do the 1/4
times 12 first this is the associative
property of multiplication so it doesn't
matter if we have a bunch of numbers and
we're multiplying them so we have 9
halves times 1/4 times 12 the
associative property of multiplication
tells us that it really doesn't matter
which multiplications we do first when
we just have a bunch of numbers being
multiplied so we can do these first and
the reason why I'm doing this first is
because because 1/4 times 12 is very
simple that's the same thing as 12
divided by 4 or if you want to think
about it this way cuz 1/4 times 12 over
1 which would be 12 over 4 which is
equal to which is equal to 3 and so that
simplified things a good bit now the
whole thing becomes 9 halves times 3 or
9 halves times 3 over 1 which is going
to be equal to 27 27 over 2 if we wanted
to write that as a mixed number it's an
improper fraction right now this would
be 2 goes into 27 13 times with the
remainder 1 so it'll be 13 and 1/2 just
to show you that it is the same thing as
if we just evaluated it this way let's
do it that way as well so if you did the
9 1/2 times the 1/4 first we would have
gotten 9 over 9 over 2 times 4 is 8
we've got 9/8 here and then we would
have had to multiply that times 12 we
could multiply it times 12 over 1 we
would you could just multiply them but
an easier thing would it be to simplify
the numerator in the denominator before
you multiply them so the eventual
numerator let's divide that by 4 we get
three over here let's divide the
eventual denominator by 4 if it divided
by the same thing as you divide the
numerator by so you get a 2 so this is
going to be 9 times 3 is 27 over 2 times
1 which is 2 which is the exact same
answer